one of the more striking points in your
book
is
when when we first met each other dave
when we first became pals you were an
atheist
today you are
not exactly an atheist no i i am a
believer there is no question about it i
am willing to say that knowles
how did it happen
there are conservatives who
hold to the traditional view of marriage
obviously who are religious who who
check all of these boxes who simply will
not agree with you on on your more
libertarian positions and then the
question is
can
can everyone work together to stop the
woke threat
without without giving up their own
views in the meantime
so
as i said i don't know that i have the
answer to that fully well i know that i
don't have the answer to that you don't
have the answer none of us do because
it's a work in progress right so we're
not there yet and maybe there is no
there there maybe it's just a project
that will just continue sort of as long
as america is to continue but what i
would say is generally speaking right
now in 2022 america and this very much
is the purpose of the book we have to
defeat the woke thing
and and we have to give the devil is due
they've done a hell of a lot of damage
they have destroyed so many things
including imploding disney right now and
i basically despise star wars at this
point because of what they have done to
it so they've destroyed our educational
institutions our financial institutions
i mean they've really
wrecked havoc over everything we should
acknowledge that so okay there there's
that
so it's that versus the rest of us the
the the groups that you just decided now
i would argue
in essence
we have to put aside some of our
differences while we build the new stuff
while we build the new internet pipes
while we build the new businesses
jeremy's razors while we build the new
entertainment companies payment
processors the whole freaking thing now
if we can really build some some good
things and of course they're all going
to be built in red states obviously
the question is after that if we can get
to that that there there
then what do we do how do we then once
we've you know we've gotten to the
promised land so to speak now the other
issues are going to start popping up
again wait a minute you gay married
people and you catholic traditionalists
we've got a problem here or whatever
that is now we're going to have to work
through that again i think the founding
documents
give us the best path forward to that
continuing to base it on individual
rights and i i personally respect
religious liberty as long as it does not
step on my individual liberty i know
that some religious conservatives don't
love that um and there's there's reasons
for that but that's the stuff we have to
hash out that that's worthy of hashing
out because the alternative michael is
at the end of the day if we don't do
this thing they want we get running
it's over congratulations we're all in
the gulag together and then we're going
to really have to live together in small
cells and eat gruel and it's very cold
and wet in there and you know i don't
know that i want to be in there with you
well so since you bring it up you bring
up this word sanctity you bring up sort
of these religious questions you
mentioned you know we've got to hash
this out cardinal manning famously said
all politics all human conflict
basically is theological at the bottom
one of the more striking points in your
book
is
when when we first met each other dave
when we first became pals you were an
atheist
yeah today you are
not exactly an atheist
no i i am a believer there is no
question about it i i'm willing to say
that knowles
how did it happen
look there there were a couple things
you know partly
one of the reasons i had never as an
adult i had never said i was an atheist
until about
000 i think it was if i remember exactly
correctly it was the fall of 2015.
so i am now in 2022 i'm 45 years old so
you know it's about seven years ago i'm
in my late 30s and i always sort of felt
somewhat agnostic but i always loved
logic and reason i grew up reading all
of carl sagan's books so i loved sort of
i loved sort of a distant respect for
belief in a way but not like a hardcore
belief something like that um you know i
also i come from a secular jewish family
that while we did all of the holidays
and traditions which is which is
basically what kept jews around for five
thousand years um it's different in
terms of the belief in god is a little
bit different than say than say a
catholic or we like to we like to say
secular judaism is jewish
you know emphasis on the ish yeah and by
the way our good friend dennis prager
has written many books about this that
maybe that thing just can't last that
long that it's not enough to like
seinfeld and eat bagels and all of those
things although those are worthy those
are worthy things man i made a an
everything bagel with lox the other day
miami you can get it they say it's all
in new york and jersey i know you're a
new yorker originally yes you can get a
good bagel down here in miami but
because where did where did the new york
jews go they've all fled now right
they're all all heading down to the free
state of florida all the sane ones now
are in florida and it's just the bananas
one still in new york uh but in any
essence i i in 2015 i started having a
bunch of well-known atheists on my show
primarily sam harris was sort of the
first one
and i just sort of started going into
that world and for a long time i never
said i was an atheist but a lot of
people just kept saying dave's an
atheist because it was just by the
nature of the conversations that i was
having uh i had ion hercialeon and pete
pagozian who wrote uh a manual for
creating atheists and michael shermer
from skeptic magazine i know you know
all these guys yeah and and so i just
sort of got
like sort of caught up in that thing but
then eventually i started saying i was
an atheist i would say a couple things
started moving beyond this first off as
you know a couple years later i was on
tour with jordan peterson and we did 120
shows in 20 countries and he was not
only i had read 12 rules for life and i
had flipped through maps of meaning it's
a very intense book um but being on tour
with this guy and every night hearing a
different speech
related to the importance
of belief and that in many ways you
whether you believe you are or not you
are a believer uh so i don't mean this
to to attack sam harris for example but
sam harris says you know he's not a
believer he's an atheist but it's like
he does believe that trump is the devil
that that's where all of his actions
over the last couple years politically
seem to come from i i don't know he
might not believe in god but he does
believe in the devil that's a great
observation ah i get one a show that's
what i always say um that
then i heard jordan say a few things
related to belief specifically that i
really loved one of them you may have
heard this he was on uh this is a little
bit later actually so i'm jumping ahead
a bit but he was on tucker carlson's fox
nation show and he was talking about the
nature of belief and he said that when
he was in his early 20s he he decided to
tell the truth for the sake of telling
the truth that in essence that if you
told the truth that that would be the
best outcome no matter what doesn't mean
that it would be a good outcome because
obviously you can tell the truth and
they might hang you for it but actually
it would be the best outcome that's an
incredible leap of faith to believe in
truth for truth's sake there's no
tangible reason to believe that in many
cases there's the reverse of that
because we know what happens to truth
tellers right you're going to be
lambasted and ask jesus you're going to
there's a lot of things that are bad
that are going to happen right
but i really love that explanation of
truth that that truth for truth's sake
is a leap of faith in and of itself
what a great colonel that is to start
with something and then you know through
the year of hearing jordan talk about
this and really also it wasn't just
at a personal level for me because i do
the politics thing that you do as well
i you know i talk about things broadly
at a societal level and it's like
it's not working without belief
once you remove god nietzsche said you
know god is dead but that's a warning to
you people that's not that you know
people think oh god's dead let's do
whatever the hell we want but it's
actually a warning because it's like man
that hole is big that hole is big and
you're going to fill it with some other
crazy [ __ ] and congratulations now boys
are girls non-racists are racist two
plus two is 5. the litany of latinx and
all the other nonsensical phrases that
we have um that's what we filled it with
we we filled it with secularism on
steroids it's not to say that secularism
and your ability to live as you wish is
not important of course it's important
and i want to live in a largely secular
society obviously but we need some
guardrails on that so i would say
you know some people's belief is purely
it's purely spiritual they they feel a a
very deep spiritual sense of belief
i wouldn't say that's the primary driver
of mine i would say it's it's a logical
it's a logical rational and almost
necessary need for belief i would say um
but i certainly feel it more maybe it's
a little bit i'm 45 now so this is
definitely what i suppose they call
middle age you young whippersnapper and
so maybe it's a little bit of that maybe
it's also it was one of the things that
that made me want to finally have kids
after not wanting to have kids for a
long time um
there's something going on here that's
beyond us knowles and i think i think
societies have to understand that
otherwise the winds of of the day will
will blow over the whole thing every
time we are in the middle of it right
now if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell